hello everybody my name is markiplier
and ignore my face I was getting
emotional I was spending my evening
doing my normal activity of crying
gratuitously but in all seriousness I'm
going to be unapologetically emotional
in this video so if that's not to your
taste then buckle up it's about to get
teary-eyed adhere and I know this is a
weird video to post after I just kind of
like threw everyone for a loop with that
last video I and and I realized after I
posted that one that I've never been
happier to make videos which is weird
considering i-i'm I'm extremely
emotional but you know if there's one
thing that I am it's always open and
honest with how I feel and the way I
feel in terms of making videos in the
way I feel in terms of talking with you
guys you know that's changed and evolved
over time but the one thing that I've
always stayed true to or at least have
always tried to is you know what this
means to me
I had me you know I haven't gotten
emotional in a video since probably like
close to 8 million subscriber mouse a
video and after I posted that video
cuz I was thinking you know I was
sitting around my house and I was just
like what are we gonna make today
I hate I shot it I edited it I posted it
I was watching all the reaction it was
just like I'm not even over who killed
burger bar oh god you can't do this to
me and I loved that I loved it not
because I was messing with people but
because there was there was like real
emotions out of it you know because
after after I posted that I was walking
around my house at me like I was
thinking out this story of where was
gonna go it was like oh
after I post that one I can do this and
this and this and you know I can make I
can make this other story and then I
started thinking about
everything that I've made up until this
point in the six years that I've been
making videos and I've been I was
thinking about you know where I've come
from and and the road that that took me
to this point in my life where I'm able
to make whatever I want and and even I'm
not a hundred percent happy with what
I'm making you guys are so understanding
that you give me the opportunity to take
a break and step back and then come back
at it harder than ever before and and I
remember every day that I made videos I
remember every single video that I've
ever made I remember the people that
I've met on this journey I remember the
people that I've lost and everything in
my mind coming to this point where I am
where I'm so lucky to be in a position
where you guys look up you guys look up
to me with hope and you look to me for
guidance and I try my best to be able to
provide that to you and I've tried my
best and this weird ride that I've been
on especially this past year this past
year has been such an emotional like
growing point for me and again I'm not
crying because I'm sad I don't want
anyone to everything that it may be sad
memories have happened in my life but I
don't regret a single one of them
you know like past mistakes and
everything that's led to this point
those those moments made me who I am
today they're gonna make me who I am in
the future and and and if anything like
the one thing that always gets me yes I
remember the person that I was before I
started doing you
and before I started forging my own path
and before you guys started believing in
me and I remember I remember that the
one thing the only thing that I wanted
and I didn't expect anything else coming
from it but the one thing that I always
wanted was I wanted to be proud of
myself and I never expected that
millions of others would be proud of me
too you know that is by far the greatest
gift I've ever been given in my life
because I don't know where I'm going you
know no one just everyone who's ever
lived is flying by the seat of their
pants we're all doing fine you're doing
fine I'm doing fine I'm doing more than
fine I know it doesn't seem like it
right now with tears and snot running
down my face but I am so unbelievably
grateful it's so unbelievably happy to
be where I am and to see how far I've
come
[Music]
because like I said I remember every
moment in my journey to get to this
point I remember every single thing
every video I've done every feeling
that's cause every person I've met every
life I've impacted in one way or another
it isn't about the specific things that
I do in my videos it's about the fact
that we can all take a moment and take a
breather and we can enjoy a silly moment
together and we can we can love
something for the sake of loving
something and not because of what it's
done you know we can explore the you
know we we can explore the unknown
together and we can be afraid and we can
be vulnerable and we can be open that's
fine and we can take the time to
discover who we need to be you know
people will constantly criticize you no
matter where you go and people will
constantly try to break you down and it
does not matter because no one can know
you more than you
I can't even know you I wanna know if
there's one thing that I know so I want
to feel so much more then what we see
through the screen and you know I joke
about it sometimes I do and it's all in
good fun but I always realize how
serious like the statements that people
make you know how people say that I
saved their life you know I don't take
that lightly
because I've seen that in the eyes of
kids I've met through the make-a-wish
Foundation I've seen that through the
people that I've met at conventions I've
seen it on the Internet I've seen it on
message boards I've seen it and the
gifts that people give me not tangible
gifts but like real emotional gifts
because I don't place value in things I
place value in people and I joke about
me getting emotional on camera because
it's true and it's honest the only thing
I've ever wanted to be is proud of
myself I I can never thank you guys
enough
I got a been rambling for a while my
point my point is I get emotional and
I'm open and honest with you guys
because that's what matters the
connection that we have the connection
of the community has the connection that
we instill in others and this journey
that we're taking together and where
it's gonna lead next I have no idea I
have no idea where it's gonna go next
but I can't I can't
I can't wait for the next adventure I
cannot wait to see what we're gonna make
next so thank you everybody so much for
watching again sorry for the late night
upload and sorry for the scare
unfortunately there's more on the way
because I've got a plan and it's
a changement plan 15 times but I can't
wait this is the greatest gift a person
could ever ask for
despite all the pain despite all the
hard work despite all the struggle and
the internal like learning of myself I'm
grateful for every step just know that
if an idiot like me can go from being
the least confident person who never
speaks out for himself to who you see in
front of you which may or not be him
here may not be an improvement
depending on your metrics but if I can
do it you can
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye bye
bye guys bye